des bassins trop cher pour les scolaires
à l'ouverture en 2022 du centre
aqualudique Castalia à morepa le
collectif piscine pour tous s'inquiète
en cause des augmentations de tarifs sur
la location des lignes d'eau entre
l'ancienne piscine municipale fermée en
2015 et le nouveau complexe pour Rael
morpa et l' encours signa le contrat de
délégation de service public en janvier
2020 confiant à la société Fage la
construction et exloitation de Castalia
selon la quarantaine de membres du
collectif les principales victimes sont
les écoles du territoire les élèves les
collèges et les lycées ne pouvant plus
venir à la piscine en raison du coup
exorbitant des lignes d'eau qui sont
passé de 6,50 € en 2015 à 46,60 € en
2022 donc à l'époque de la piscine
municipale au collège
pergot nous avions les moyens d'emmener
toutes nos classes à la piscine
évidemment les choix ont dû se faire et
c'est la classe de 6e
qui a été choisi pour bénéficier de cet
enseignement pour le maire de moropa
grégoryi garestier ces TIF s'inscrivent
dans la moyenne des équipements des
alentours il réaffirme qu'il est à la
charge des communes de financer les
créneaux de natation pour les élèves des
écoles maternelles et primairire en ce
qui concerne les collèges et les lycées
des crédits pour les locations des
lignes d'eau leur sont alloués par le
département et la région aujourd'hui sur
la totalité des établissements on en a
un qui rencontre des difficultés mais
qui rencontre des difficulté également
lié à des problématiques de gestion au
sein de son établissement avec des choix
peut-être d'action pédagogique qui ont
été faites dans les années passées quand
l'équipement était fermé et aujourd'hui
c'est plus difficile j'allais dire de
faire des arbitrages il comparent un
tarif de 2014 ou 2015 qui n'a rien à
voir ce n'est pas du tout le même
équipement l'équipement dont il parle à
6 € la ligne d'eau j'allais dire il
était déjà payé puisque c'est la ville
de morpac qui en a récupérer la gestion
en 1983 quand elle est sortie de 50 an
iveline contacter le centre aqualudique
Castalia n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
sollicitation ce mardi 6 février les
membres du collectif piscine pour tous
se réuniront dans la soirée devant
l'entrée du conseil municipal de morepa
ils souhaitent rencontrer le maire pour
exprimer leurs
craintes